Leslie Jones best Twitter reactions to
the Winter Olympics Shay Mitchell
streaking through LA plus the Beckham's
at New York Fashion Week it's all here
on the daily Denny hello people while
you are out and about enjoying your
weekend
Team USA was out in Pyeongchang making
history at the Winter Olympic Games are
you guys watching because these athletes
got me hollering at the TV
give it up
yep that was me watching Adam rip on
make his Olympic debut in the men's free
skate competition and listen the boy
came out looking like Elsa and let it go
I mean he dazzled but he did not place
him first
and that did not sit well with one
Leslie Jones wait a minute wait a second
place um excuse him why wait a minute
second place to whom not the villain I
know not the damn building the village
school he fell twice so you're telling
me you can fall twice and still coming
first
hey who's judging I need to know what's
up with the points on this one the
Saturday Night Live star turned
everyone's favorite Olympic commentator
served up some more hilarious reactions
while watching the games over the
weekend including witness team Orion
Agassi make history by becoming the
first u.s. woman to land a triple axel
in Olympic competition nailed it
that's right mother because I'd like to
see you put her at third place not gonna
I love it I love it I'm here for it but
perhaps the best reaction from Leslie
came while watching Teen USA loser Chris
Masters history-making run on Saturday
Chris is the first American to ever
medal in the men's singles luge
competition but it wasn't just Chris's
athleticism Leslie was into she liked
much of the Internet also took note of
his attractiveness okay here you go
Chris that was on his phone earlier but
he must be good he is fine as hell I
know that much that's for damn show
Chris why don't you luzo over here to my
place boy I'm way more dangerous than
that though that little skateboard with
all right just listen the thirst is real
folks
Leslie deserves a medal for her
commentary alone I am so here for it and
thankfully we've got a couple more weeks
of the games and tonight Shaun White
returns to the snowboarding halfpipe and
wow this is the most I've ever talked
about sports so let's move on to an
other star was something to celebrate
Shay Mitchell the Pretty Little Liars
alum recently hit 3 million subscribers
on her YouTube channel so how does she
ring in the milestone well by streaking
in the streets of Los Angeles
naturally meanwhile Victoria Beckham in
considerable amount of clothes Rock New
York Fashion Week with her stylish
family in tow
the Beckham's took over the city
stepping out looking like that -
Victoria show and I mean come on
well me and my family ever looked that
good probably not
but they were there without Big Brother
Brooklyn he stayed in LA where he
attended a Spice Girls theme drag show
to celebrate his girlfriend Chloe Moretz
his 21st birthday meanwhile you guys
remember when Victoria Beckham posted
this reunion photo earlier this month
fans thought or sure the ladies were
heading back on the road but sorry folks
poss just put a stop to all those rumors
telling British Vogue quote I'm not
going on tour the girls aren't going on
tour but Victoria did hint that the
girls talk some business after
get-together saying quote what is that
in the future what does that look like
we're just bouncing ideas around
brainstorming well shake a leg ladies
because I'm ready to get my zig-zig ah
alright thank you alright for these
stories and more head over to ET
online.com slash daily Denny thank you
guys for watching give me a shot in the
comment section with the snowflake emoji
if you're as obsessed with the Winter
Olympics as I am right now I am a luge
my way out of here to lunch
[Music]